avec moi en plateau ce soir Pascal
Renaud bonsoir alors vous êtes la mère
adjoint délégué à l'événementiel et à la
vie associative pour la commune de
Fontenay-le-Fleury samedi prochain vous
organisez une après-midi olympique sur
le plateau Descartes au programme de
nombreuses animations des découvertes
sportives mais aussi de nombreux
athlètes quels sont quels sont les
animations prévues et quelles seront les
athlètes de haut niveau présent alors
serait une journée comme on l'a jamais
faite à Fontenay-le-Fleury une journée
ou sur un même site un même lieu on va
pouvoir faire santé culture
développement durable pratiquer un sport
et surtout rencontrer des athlètes comme
vous le dites donc on a la chance
d'avoir des athlètes
comme Guy mormain qui est guilh
handisport ancien athlète de haut niveau
qui a été demi-finaliste du 200 mètres
au championnat du monde handisport à
Hassen qui sera avec qui sera tout à
l'heure il arrive qui a été médaille
d'or du 100 mètres 200 mètres et 400
mètres avec Assia elanouni aux Jeux
paralympiques d'Athènes 2004 on aura
Ivan wanji qui est un joueur
qui a été médaillée d'or aux Championnat
d'Europe en 2022 huitième aux Jeux
paralympiques de Tokyo on aura
Christopher mi-sang pour la boxe il a
été champion de France et champion de
France des 69 kg on aura une judoka
Marie-Claire resto qui a été médaillé
d'or au championnat de du monde 1995 et
1997 et qui a vraiment propulsé judo
français
elle avait mes décroché le olympique
Atlanta de beau palmarès oui et puis on
a Florian grimbaud qui est un coureur
cycliste sur piste spécialiste de
vitesse et en 2021 il était vice
champion du monde et mets des bronze aux
Jeux olympiques en vitesse par équipe à
Tokyo le programme s'annonce chargé
parce qu'elle Renaud pour ce samedi
après-midi il y en aura pour tous les
goûts qu'on soit aussi bien sportif ou
un peu plus un peu un peu moins sportif
plus porté sur le théâtre je crois tout
à fait il y en aura pour tous les goûts
en fait on va parler aussi bien santé
donc on aura des professionnels de santé
qui sont là nutrition
ostéopathe kiné il y aura donc la
possibilité de de pouvoir discuter avec
eux sur je suis blessée je suis malade
est-ce qu'il y a un sport qui est adapté
pour moi on pourra tester sa forme
physique puisque le Comité olympique
nous met à disposition le village
olympique donc il y aura un stand de
santé donc voilà donc ça c'est la
première étape c'est se dire que
finalement la seule limite en général
c'est nous on est notre propre ennemi et
que tout le monde peut faire ne
serait-ce qu'une activité une activité
physique marcher on peut tous se faire
voilà on a vu avec le covid
la santé c'est important aujourd'hui on
a le numérique qui rentre dans le dans
le travail on est de plus en plus
sédentaire et il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse bouger donc ce pôle santé il est
important et pourquoi pourquoi faire
venir des nutritionnistes des
kinésithérapeutes des ostéopathes
c'était aussi pour susciter des
dévocations peut-être chez les plus
jeunes ou alors pourquoi pas mais c'est
aussi pour se dire que le sport c'est
quel sport est adapté alors je suis
sportive finalement peut-être que je
fais pas à la bonne fréquence c'est
peut-être pas forcément le bon sport
c'est peut-être pas forcément le bon
dosage donc c'est aussi avoir
ce retour d'un spécialiste quand je suis
sur mon vélo j'ai peut-être pas
forcément la bonne position voilà donc
c'est avoir ce retour ou quand je suis
blessée qu'est-ce que je peux faire
qu'est-ce que je ne peux pas faire donc
c'était pouvoir répondre à toutes les
questions des sportifs dénonce sportifs
des plus jeunes et des moins jeunes donc
ce pôle santé il est vraiment c'est
finalement c'est l'entrée en matière
ensuite on a la partie culture qui est
importante et je voudrais que le sport
fasse vraiment ce lien avec la culture
mais pourquoi intégrer de la culture
dans cette alors ça fait partie des ça
fait partie des JO la culture la culture
et est un axe des Jeux Olympiques et
finalement le sport va nous emmener là
où on ne l'attend pas et voilà la
culture donc il y aura un match d'impro
et finalement on va pouvoir tester son
aisance verbale on sera dans le même
dans une la même logique un match de
tennis les 16e les 8e etc et à la fin de
la journée on aura les jeunes du foot de
la section foot du collège les 6e qui
vont nous faire le représentation
puisque
ils ont un projet avec le théâtre donc
ce lien se porte théâtre un sport
culture en tout cas c'est pour nous
c'est un héritage qui doit perdurer
après l'ijo c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment important donc il y aura de la
culture il y aura bien sûr à la pratique
d'activité sportive ce soit
voilà du rugby de l'escrime du basket
mais on aura aussi les nouvelles
disciplines l'escalade le breakdance et
puis des disciplines paralympiques avec
le Cécifoot le hand fauteuil et le
tennis de table en fauteuil c'est
important d'intégrer ces disciplines par
olympiques
tout à fait c'est important de se dire
que finalement le sport voilà il est
ouvert à tous on peut dépasser
son handicap en arrivant vanji qui nous
lira très bien puisque lui il a perdu la
vue il avait 10 ans et finalement
aujourd'hui il est hors de question de
lui dire que la première chose qu'on
remarque chez lui c'est qu'il ne voit
pas c'est un athlète qui justement peut
nous faire nous faire nous dépasser et
aussi enfin voilà c'est on peut on peut
aller là où on finalement on ne sait pas
qu'on peut aller
vous êtes guide handisport pourquoi
c'était important pour vous de
participer à cet après-midi olympique
j'interviens souvent beaucoup au niveau
des associations et voilà moi j'aime
bien
c'est un peu mon cheval de bataille de
pouvoir montrer à tout un chacun comment
se dépasser comment aussi appréhender le
handicap parce que c'est une forme de
c'est une sensibilisation aussi en
France on a beaucoup de mal à
appréhender le handicap et avec en plus
la venue des jeux ça va nous permettre
aussi de surpasser un petit peu cette
cette notion voilà cette impression que
peut avoir les notamment les adultes
parce que les enfants en général
il participe en difficulté à des
sensibilisations handicales handisports
alors que les adultes ils sont un petit
peu peur de se mettre dans un fauteuil
ou de se mettre en déficience visuel ou
autre de peur d'être handicapés par la
suite et donc vous allez faire des
démonstrations voilà moi je vais mettre
en situation les personnes avec quel que
soit ça peut être aussi des personnes en
situation de handicap
en déficience visuelle leur habituel
avec une avoir une
double un double handicap par exemple et
voir comment ils pourront se débrouiller
aussi tout en s'amusant parce que
l'objectif aussi c'est c'est de le faire
et de prendre du plaisir ou de s'amuser
et alors donc on le disait beaucoup de
sport vous il y avait il y a aussi
d'autres sports un peu moins classiques
comme le breakdance l'escalade qui sont
de nouveaux sports olympiques c'était
une volonté ça aussi tout à fait de
pouvoir les proposer et de pouvoir les
tester et de se dire finalement c'est
pour moi j'y vais voilà d'ouvrir les
horizons ça je pense que c'est important
et il y aura aussi du laser run cours
entière en Corée en tir voilà d'accord
et bien écoutez merci beaucoup à vous
deux d'avoir accepté notre invitation si
vous êtes intéressé par l'Olympie des
c'est samedi prochain de 14h30 à 18h30
sur le plateau des cartes de
Fontenay-le-Fleury